let me ask a different question so i
remember we were in the army okay and
you go into formation you had a long
weekend you partied hard and one weekend
i'm doing guard duty and we have this
one guy if i say the name no one's gonna
know this guy's but his name was jackson
only the guys that were at the unit
would know
this guy was chris tucker
uh combined with dave chappelle
hilarious guy but he loved smoking weed
and in the army you couldn't smoke weed
if you did you get caught you know
you're going getting an article 15 and
et cetera and we had another guy i can't
say his name because his last name is
very unique he was a cocaine guy so
on one end of the hall we had a mountain
of cocaine i walked in one i'm like dude
what are you doing he said but david you
can't tell anybody dog you know
how the hell do you have this much
cocaine you only make 800 bucks a month
how do you he says well such and such
gave it to me we followed the
distribution deal anyways so he said
such and such gave it to me but anyways
don't tell anybody you want something i
said no bro i'm totally fine but you
know what please get rid of this stuff i
think you're clinical
so now i go back to the other side so
one end the door's open they're doing
coke the other end smells like freaking
bob marley showed up out of nowhere and
resurrected and they're smoking nons and
by the way the worst part is smoke's
coming from the bottom of the what do
you call it the the door right that's
good i'm like jackson you're making i'm
responsible
i got guard duty bro you're ruining my
life right now i'm gonna get in trouble
he says do it but david dog you can't do
nothing man you gotta tell them i'm not
doing nothing i said i said here's what
i need you to do i can tell them
anything but their noses
so i said dude light up incense
everywhere so he says okay okay uh yeah
good idea dog so i go grab my incense i
get everybody to get him insane he's got
50 likes
you should see this place makes no sense
so sergeant calls me
uh bed david
yes sarge i'm coming through oh my god
listen i would suggest we start off with
the one that's the most troubled one
which is charlie company which is the
one that's the most peaceful very easy
gold star tactic right so we start with
charlie and i'm taking my time i think
we have to be careful with this floor it
was filled with you know christians and
mormons they were good kids right so i
said but you got to be careful with
these guys because you know how they are
sometimes there's a bottle of water
somewhere yes so anyways we go to second
floor i'm taking my time i'm like dude i
got like if i can 45 minutes i open the
windows everything anyways he says we
got to go to hhc because jackson's there
so jackson's the biggest sweetheart what
are you talking about
david you and i know who jackson is i
said dude
so we go there and we were walking up he
said what's that smell i said they were
barbecuing earlier
it says that that's it smell like
barbecue
something burned something burned here
he said no i smell wheat i said no it's
incense incense smells very similar
so he goes and you see the smoke coming
out of jackson's deal
dude he knocks on the door
opens the door
what's up sash
jackson wipe that look off your face so
he's got two other buddies that's
sitting there and um i said you guys
smoking weed me
i don't smoke then we we're talking
about
this
we're reading poetry this is incense
i'm like no no listen let's just go the
other way let's go the other way because
no no they're smoking with us so sorry
they're not smoking wheat he said
they're smoking with us what are you
talking about it's incense you ever had
smuggled this it doesn't smell so
anyways we leave so at this point i'm
thinking i got away with it we go to the
other side the cocaine guy covers it up
okay which by the way that ended up
going to jail for like five years
military prison bad situation because he
wouldn't stop doing cocaine you're not
supposed to do it in the army you're not
supposed to do it period but in the army
it's even worse
anyways we go to formation weekend ants
we're like guys hey big dog we made it
man you're my homie look dude we made it
we're straight up
so monday morning all right um
we're doing a random drug test
if you're social the last four of your
social starts with the number six and
four
step up so whose numbers are they it's
jackson's mine and the other guy
so i'm like hey i know i'm clean so i
step up i'm like oh jax oh dog i
don't know i don't have the what do you
call the the thing you would pour on
your uh
uh a vinegar they didn't have the
vinegar because you had to tip it and
then anyways anyway we're learning a
little too much here so yes dude i don't
have that you gotta i said dude i'm not
gonna have any so anyways we'll go get
tested and the way they test it the way
they test it is they're watching it's
not testing it go give them no no
they're not doing that so put your hands
on the side one hand only let me see
very awkward
so we come out
they said what do you think is going to
happen i said
either they're going to you're going to
test positive for incense are you going
to test positive
or barbecue
so the cocaine guy doesn't get tested
for nothing he gets away for whatever
reason now he they didn't get him they
got him six months later but they didn't
get him that time he just couldn't
hopefully help himself he was too pretty
with a guy and he would party i
introduced him to one club and he just
went crazy
jackson gets caught
and he goes demote gets committed from
specialists to e1 okay and he has to do
bathroom you know all this stuff he has
to clean up he said
i'm like jackson i told you bro so i
come up clean everybody's good we leave
jackson's out the other guy goes to
military prison and people have to
figure out probably not a good idea to
smoke weed and do cocaine in the army
right
i come out of the army i talked to one
of my friends who him and i worked at
burger king together he was the cashier
and i was the chef and so
they wouldn't make me cashier they said
he talked too much
that's a big word i was a chef listen i
like being a chef but it's
whopper no onions right
so one day we get into the biggest
debate about welfare and social security
and all these section 8 and all this
stuff i said you know what i think they
need to do he says what biggest debate
i'm curious to know what you guys will
say i said i don't mind if you're giving
unemployment benefits to people some
people need it for three six months they
recover i told you you need to give
welfare and food stamps to certain
people but here's what i think they need
to do what's that i think
every month you ought to get drug tested
if you test positive you don't get
taxpayer money
if you test negative listen we'll help
you out but there's one criteria you
cannot do drugs he lost his mind he says
that's not fair
what would it take if we were to drug
test people that are getting
you know whatever it is wic any of this
stuff that we're getting what percentage
of people do you think wouldn't get the
benefits
well you know through the 80s and 90s
you know you would have a tremendous
percent of people under 30 that test
positive marijuana and don't get the
benefits and now you've got 25 states
where it's perfectly legal to go get
high and just go buy it at the drug
store you can get edibles and whatever
you want the you know process
what what patrick you're saying is in
order to qualify you have to be
90 percent
i don't think it's that high
no no i was going to say a fifth dude
adam adam right now is rolling i don't
think it's 90 percent no i i would say
at least a third i'm gonna go with the
third i think that's conservative okay
let's just say a high of 90 which i'm
sure he's being conservative in his mind
was that a pun you're a third
let's say let's
let's say third there's a delayed
reaction this morning with patrick yeah
you don't understand
a third is he related to charlie tom
help me out here are you really serious
you only think one third of people that
get these three benefits i don't do
all month are only a third of the time
how about we say 50 okay let's just say
50 at some point during the month they
would test positive if they hit it up
90. let's say you're really jacked up
about this i thought high 90 was a
fastball but now you're talking about
drug percentage let's say 50 let's say
what do you think would happen if that
was a standard he said look no problem
you're going through tough times my rule
for unemployment how people want to get
unemployment here's my unemployment
would work what were you making at your
job four grand a month how much is
unemployment we're paying you two grand
a month that's it no problem here's what
i want you to do you're four grand a
month you were working uh 40 hours a
week i was the two grand we're giving
you unemployment i want you to give 20
hours of community service exactly and
we'll pay you two grand a month but it's
20 hours of community service as long as
you're not disabled you know how quickly
people would get off of unemployment oh
my gosh
we need community service the side of
the freeways are dirty bro we need your
help but you're so awesome we'll give
you this two thousand dollars in
exchange and a drug test once a month
let's totally do that here's your
reflective vest and your orange bag and
people would be like the side of the
freeway going my friends on this freeway
texting i do not want to be here
they would be off unemployment in 10
seconds yeah that's the point so the
point is do you want people off of
unemployment do you want people off of
welfare do you want people not you
politicians establishment do they want
people off of entitlement programs no or
do they need them on entire programs
voters
inflation it is and that's this is a
government program making inflation
higher than it would otherwise be which
is the most regressive tax in the world
inflation let me ask you this question
yeah because the people that are putting
these policies together have smart
people around them or they are smart
they're not idiots
do they think we're idiots and that
they're just gonna force feed us this as
long as they possibly can is this is
this a day-to-day game for them just to
stay relevant and to be re-elected or do
they think these policies work well let
me let me ask you a question when it
comes on to parents you think parents
are smart or you think they're dumb i
think they're smart okay good let's
qualify all parents are smart okay do
you think some parents uh who
say a father who has not been on a
picture comes back he wants to win the
kids over how do fathers try to win
their kids over money money attention
yeah what do kids later on say in life
when they have that one big fight with
their father stop trying to buy me with
what with gifts right when people grow
up some kids are going to be like dude i
love it
give me more gifts this is great but
some kids say what i don't want you i
don't want to go with money i want you
to put some time into me and help me
grow up you were not there for that time
there's going to be a percentage of
people that are going to be like this
this political party is awesome this is
great i'm loving this but there's going
to be a few people that are going to be
like listen i'm sick and tired it's
sick and tired of it listen i
got it i got it you can't buy me with
money i don't want any of these
entitlement programs i mean again 61 of
these 73 million children in america 90
what percentage of americans know that
they're getting money that they don't
need and are pissed off a lot i mean i
heard people well i don't know about
pissed off because probably but you know
i've heard people say like why isn't
this money going to people who really
need it why am i getting this money i
don't know that that's a reaction i hear
people say that all the time i just got
a deposit i i don't know why they're
sending me money right i mean people
that probably don't need it they're
still getting the hand out yeah you know
it's crazy we had a board meeting last
week tom was in the room and one of my
investors gets up and he says you know
last year i called pat and i called pat
i said hey they're giving away the ppp
loans okay and we can get pretty much
free money i said what's the number he
says a little bit less than 5 million
bucks we can get if we go get it but
remember we don't have to pay this back
i said why are we why why do we take the
money says listen just take the money
you don't need to worry about it because
we don't have to take it back you can i
said take the money and run i said i'm
not doing it bro it says so then they
call another board member to call me and
say we should take this money i said we
have money why am i taking 5 million
bucks he said because they're doing it
for everybody and i said i'm not going
to do it so he brought up this story to
say pat didn't want to take it why am i
taking the money if i want to be fine i
don't need this money give it to people
that are struggling the restaurant owner
that's getting crushed right give him
that exactly they need tremendous help
exactly we're going to be okay well the
board should be happy that you took that
stance integrity you know well
sure but that board member is a very
very uh driven uh by the numbers guy and
i love him but he's actually a business
guy great guy by the way fantastic guy
but it is what it is anyway so we'll see
what's going to happen here with these
numbers and the direction inflation is
going so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]